Monsieur fury ricotta lito s vous venez de
quitter pour jouer les premiers
artistes conceptuels est l'une des premières
personnes à commencer à travailler sur un film,
ils nous voient en quelque sorte comme une transition
de la bande dessinée à quelque chose de
plus proche du film, généralement nous commencerons à
travailler  en essayant de concevoir un personnage
une sorte de conception de tron moments pour le film
ue Marvel est vraiment intéressé à rendr
emblématique, ils utiliseront essentiellement des illus
rations et des conceptions comme base pour const
uire le film à part l'idée vamp oj oj delan
y i Coupe de Belson ball jicam
a  une grande partie de ma compassion amoureuse pour ces
personnages vient du fait d'avoir vécu plus
que quand j'étais enfant et de
lire les bandes dessinées pour moi
qui grandissait, c'était une chose énorme et
je voulais juste être ce
personnage le gars mais les gens
admiré et pensé que c'était une bonne personne, donc
c'est un énorme rêve énorme pour moi parce
que je n'aurais jamais pensé que je finirais
par être capable de faire ça
pour vivre dans un profil aussi élevé, vous savez
mai  nstream films en
tant que fan de ces personnages, j'ai toujours l'
impression qu'il est assez important d'essayer
de maintenir autant que possible les
bandes dessinées et de garder qu'il est important au moins
de mon point de vue de les faire
ressembler si les acteurs deviennent
le  les personnages que nous venons de vous fournir
savent comme ça peut-être le chemin pour
leur permettre de devenir le personnage mais
que la fin Chris Evans se sent un capitaine
américain Tony jeune Robert Downey jr.  est
Tony Stark et chris hemsworth est un
disque solaire c'était Ethel a fait plus me rend
heureux en tant que fan en tant qu'artiste que
ces personnages
un souvenir d'enfance se réunissent à l'
écran pour finalement garder le nom de
Warren Buffett l'
une des choses essaie simplement d'imaginer
comment ils  regarderaient tous ensemble, je veux dire,
c'était vous savez trouver un moyen pour que Thor
puisse se tenir à côté d'Iron Man et de
Captain America, c'était en quelque sorte le
défi de notre groupe était de faire un
assez bon travail sur chacun des personnages
que lorsque vous mettez  ensemble que ce
serait euh, ils seraient vraiment super,
j'espère que les gens sont tous enthousiasmés par
le travail que les studios Marvel sont en train de faire
et et je peux dire que j'en étais une petite
partie